that
we also need to roll out as certainly as
far as you're concerned and the
government will be making the point
later on today are these um heat pumps
um but it is going to be voluntary at
least for now is what we heard from the
government minister this morning do you
think that's the right way forward
no i don't and i think everyone's in a
bit of shock this morning to be honest
because we all thought that there was
going to be a legal requirement by a
certain date in the 2030s whether that's
2032 or 2035 that beyond that date there
will be uh it will be legally impossible
to buy a new gas boiler now we're just
hearing that the government is is
backtracking on that and i think what
you can see here really is the impact of
an almighty row between the treasury and
number 10 and the treasury has clearly
won and therefore the funding that's
really required to to get these heat
pumps into people's homes fast enough
simply isn't there so i think that's one
real concern that we don't have the
funding to really scale up at the kind
of pace that we need on these heat pumps
and secondly it seems just such an
extraordinary mission not to have put in
at the same package a really
comprehensive home insulation scheme we
know that heat pumps are only going to
work well if your home is insulated and
there simply isn't enough money in this
package to properly insulate homes
either so i'm afraid this is yet another
of boris johnson's you know big flagship
policies that when you start to look at
some of the details
they're simply not there
and that on the eve of the of the cop
climate summit this big glasgow summit
in in a couple of weeks time i think
that's sending a very bad signal
um as far as insulating your homes is
concerned i mean do you still think that
it's a good idea for environmental
protesters to sit down and block the m25
i've said before that i think what they
should be blocking is the treasury i
mean i think we need to be putting the
the the pressure on those people who are
making these decisions it's not
motorists on the m25 who are making
decisions about rolling out insulation
it's rishi chancellor the fossil fuel
chancellor uh in the uh in the treasury
so that's why we need to be putting
pressure i'm really sorry that it looks
as if the treasury has won out in the
battle over whether or not enough
funding is going to be put in into this
program you only have to compare the uk
with other countries in terms of how
we're doing uh rolling out um
heat pumps you know we've basically only
put out around a quarter of the heat
pumps that they have in germany a sixth
of the number that they have in in italy
a tenth of the number in france so we're
really lagging behind other european
countries this was the opportunity to
scale up at the speed uh and at the
scale that the science demands and the
government splunked it and that is a
real tragedy both for all of those
people who are living in fuel poverty
who can't afford to keep their homes
warm but also in terms of our climate
emissions as well the kind of insulation
program that so many people want to see
this comprehensive street by street
local authority led program would not
only get people's emissions down it
would get their fuel bills down but it
would also create hundreds of thousands
of jobs in every single constituency in
the country it is a massively lost
opportunity you're not suggest
advocating i should say the blocking of
government buildings though are you
really
i'm advocating when it's necessary
peaceful direct action and i've never
been afraid to do that and i've taken
that kind of action right now it's
illegal to block a government building
that'd be illegal wouldn't it
um
the the whole point about peaceful
direct action is that that you create
some kind of obstruction what i'm simply
saying is that rather than if you're
going to take it would be illegal
some sometimes there are bigger
illegalities we're facing at the moment
the issue of an existential threat to
life on earth i think that in that
context if people do choose to take
peaceful direct action they are
legitimate to do that they take the the
legal consequences
but i'm suggesting okay if i could just
finish what i'm suggesting is you know
i'm challenged
a robust conversation you're advocating
people breaking the law blocking the
doors to the treasury and i'm saying
that's illegal um and i'm asking you to
um
say whether you are advocating people
acting in an illegal way for the greater
good is that what you're saying
i'm saying that sometimes when there is
a greater illegality if you like if you
think about our legal commitments to to
get our emissions down if you think
about the fact that climate change poses
an existential threat to life on earth
i'm saying that sometimes there are
occasions when peaceful direct action is
legitimate even if that means breaking
the law if it's done in a peaceful way
i'm saying that rather than blocking the
m25 where what you're essentially doing
is is putting yourself in the way of of
people who have absolutely no influence
over government policy if people are
choosing to take that kind of action it
would make an awful lot more sense to do
it when the people that they are
focusing on are the decision makers
right now we've got a decision maker in
the treasury the chancellor who is not
putting the funding behind the kind of
program that we need to see to get our
homes insulated to shift away from the
fossil fuel economy that is one of the
most serious issues that we face today
and i'm saying that i think if people do
take peaceful direct action in that
cause then i i i could quite understand
why they would do that
yeah but it can't be legitimate if it's
illegal that's an oxymoron
no it's not uh the suffragettes the um
civil rights movement and they got
arrested
they were arrested and then the law was
subsequently changed but it was illegal
so they were arrested
i'm not i'm not arguing about whether
it's legal or not what i'm arguing yeah
you were you said it was legitimate
action it's not legitimate if it's
illegal
that's where i'm differing with uk i'm
saying that there can be action that is
both legal uh illegal and legitimate in
certain circumstances i'm certainly not
advocating it lightly but i am saying
for example when i was arrested uh for
intervening um sitting down outside a
fracking protest i was subsequently uh
found to to to not have committed a
crime but i sat down there i was
arrested for that i was prepared to take
the legal consequences because fracking
was on the front line of a whole new
fossil fuel
industry i think that right now when
literally what we're talking about is
the livability of this planet going
forward i would not want to be able to
look into the eyes of future generations
and explain why i didn't take every
peaceful action that i could to try to
make sure that we get our emissions down
right now what we're talking about is
this government's new uh plan the
sadness is the tragedy is that the plan
is not going to be enough to get us
where we need to be even according to
the government's own advisors the
committee on climate change and
therefore i think it is right that
people make as much noise as possible to
try to put pressure on the government to
step up and put in place the policies
that we need